survivors and families of victims of
deadly crashes across our state gathered
this evening as they were honored for
World Remembrance Day Madison Kimbrough
was at tonight's event at the Clark
County Government Center and she joins
us live in The Newsroom with this story
Madison it was an intimate setting held
outside local law enforcement County
officials and families from across the
valley came together to lend support to
one another on a topic that is all too
frequent on our roadways
now the world knows me as the sole
survivor of the car crash to kill nine
people traffic safety and education is
everybody's business and responsibility
it should be ingrained in all that we do
that was Tiffany May who was thankful to
be alive after surviving the horrendous
car crash that happened in North Las
Vegas this past January she was one of
the speakers at Sunday's World
Remembrance Day an event meant to honor
motor vehicle crash victims and
survivors due to the pandemic it's been
two years since the last one was held in
Las Vegas but with so many fatalities on
our roadways each day the need is
evident parents like Susan Smith who
dealt with her own personal tragedy in
2019 says coming to this was hard but
worth it knowing she's not alone on
March 25th of 2019 Johnny was hit and
killed walking home from school
he was 12. it's incredibly sad for me
but I I go these so I can lend strength
or get some myself and Aaron Breen
director of the road Equity Alliance
project a key speaker at Sunday's event
says while the aftermath of a traffic
fatality is never easy there is hope for
the future of our roadways there's Focus
now on literally changing our roads not
just relying on people who who are
people who are human beings and who make
mistakes so the thought process has
finally rolled around to we need to
change how we build roads you can change
a road to mitigate the inevitable
outcome of that crash so I'm so hopeful
that I'm not going to be standing here
next year talking about us having an
increase in fatalities but a decrease
and as for statistics Clark County has
seen a 22 percent increase over 2020
numbers in traffic fatalities with last
night's crash on Cheyenne and Simmons
marking the 215th fatal of this year in
The Newsroom Madison Kimbrough 8 News
Now